alors je la main comme vous êtes passés
pas loin de la mort lors de votre
accident
je vais vous faire une interview
jugement dernier c'est normal serge lama
a dû voler de l'argent dans le porte
monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais petit
jamais il n'a jamais fait pour piquer de
l'argent à ma mère c'était compliqué
savent elles étaient très grasse et puis
je piquais les sucres serge lama as-tu
copié sur ton voisin en classe pendant
les compos oui as-tu enfermer des élèves
du sexe féminin dans les cabinets non
non mais j'avais et j'avais une sale
manie quand j'étais à la maternelle ne
pas déjà mais je je piquais les petites
filles avec des épingles
et serge lama est ce que tu te repent
pour ça oui
ah oui oui serge lama as-tu par donner à
ta mère oui serge lama as tu déjà été
tentée par l'homosexualité
non et j'avais mon meilleur ami qui
était homosexuel et quand comme ça
marche et très mal quand j'étais môme
avec les avec les jeunes filles à jour
j'arrive
et puis je dire j'en ai vous j'en ai
plein mon je vais me faire [ __ ] j'en ai eu
marre
mbia mon pauvre caucourt on peut pas
voir toutes les chances en même temps
serge lama as-tu fait l'amour sans désir
de procréer oui quelle honte tu te
reposes pour saisir et même que des fois
je les fais volontairement pour ne pas
procréer
serge lama a tu trompes est capable
et c'est ta dernière chance serge lama
le jugement dernier cédant 3 10 mai et
avec ma femme c'est entrer au paradis
serge lama as-tu trompé d'un maîtresse
puis bafang serge lama 1 tu vraiment on
fait quand et les petites femmes de
pigalle et bah non non moi je suis
plutôt un type à bourgeoise un oui je
suis un peu non jeu j'aime oui serge
lama tu préfères les femmes mariées oui
comme ça tu les as pas sur le dos toute
la journée je voulais pas forcément
mariés mais aussi oui d'accord
serge lama as-tu exiger des femmes des
pratiques contre nature
j'ai pas exigée mais j'ai je leur ai
demandé gentiment
elles ont dit oui pas tout c'était